what's up reject nation happy monday to
you
i read the title for this video and i'm
gonna start off with this
i'm hoping it's true i'm really hoping
it's true
i'm just gonna start there i am too
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we're still
talking about spider-man 3 going
and with the film officially starting
filming hopefully it's like that for a
long time now but today we have
something especially for your channel
more
and ours an inside source
but rather a leaked audition tape that
has been taken down from multiple
websites already
which usually means that it's a very
legitimate video
[Music]
so if you're trying to avoid any and all
spoilers for the upcoming spider-man 3
that's going to take place in the mcu
this may not be the video
not us we'll see before we get started
congratulations i'll probably forget
for being last week's winner of the iron
spider funko pop just email me in the
email my description and i'll get you
your prize
and since so many people love this iron
spider i'll be giving it away again
this week just subscribe like the video
and comment down below
so the video has since been deleted
which is kind of always a good sign
because it usually confirms that it's
real but luckily for us at
multiverse.com posted a description on
their website
about everything that was in this leaked
audition tape a disclaimer this audition
table
is believed to be for miles morales for
spider-man 3 but it is not confirmed to
be that officially
but as you'll see it looks pretty
obvious that it is
the addition video is a two-part video
and the first part begins with a young
african-american man out delivering food
for what appeared to be his parents's
restaurant the young man is stopped by
the nypd because he is wearing some sort
of spider-man gear
when questioned by the police he states
he's a fan of spidey but it's clear that
in whatever universe this takes place
being a fan of spidey is not okay yeah
okay he seems to pick up
right after the events of spider-man far
from home where peter parker's identity
is revealed
everybody knows he's spider-man and
mysterio framed him so everybody thinks
he's a murderer so
clearly now in the mcu being a fan of
spiderman it's a great photo really a
good thing
you're essentially supporting somebody
that most people think is a criminal so
that would explain why the nypd stops
this young man who is wearing spiderman
especially young black man where he's
going to work this audition tape
in the first part of the video we see
the young man again in a conversation
with his father
and then what is believed to be his
cousin when talking to the second person
believed to be his cousin a breaking
news report airs on the television
indicating that the costumed
hero spider-man has been found dead at
the museum
now this is severely interesting because
if this is in fact a spider-man 3
it seems like spider-man is going to die
the only question
is which spider-man no
tom holland give it back to toby
could be a temporary death mcu he's very
loved by all of the fans
sony loves him and marvel loves him so i
really doubt that they're going to kill
him off
but there are many different
possibilities of what could be happening
here and in a movie where multiple
spider-man are rumored and reported to
appear in there is always the
possibility that
one spider-man may in fact die so there
really are a few different options
right right right top ones that i think
could be happening for starters i'll say
that they could kill tom holland and
then replace him with miles morales this
is absolutely absurd
i do not think this is going to happen
but i guess it's an option
[Music]
but any realistic options this could be
a spiderman that is dead
in another universe now we assume that
this character that is being auditioned
for
the young african-american man is miles
morales
and they could be doing something
similar to what they did and into the
spider verse where peter parker dies and
then miles morales takes on the mantle
yeah of course in a movie where they're
exploring the multiverse he could go
into a different universe and that's how
we could get into the main
tom holland mcu universe now as far as
which spider-man
actually dies in this universe well
depends on what universe they're in
but with rumors of andrew garfield and
toby maguire reprising their spider-man
roles it could be one of their two
universes
so we could get toby mcguire spider-man
from the sam raimi universe where he's
still with
mj harry osborne is dead but presumably
spider-man is still out but they put
that in the audition though
unfortunately it seems
yeah like kind of a specific big one
is andrew garfield spider-man from the
amazing spider-man universe
now this would tie the mcu to the
amazing spider-man universe which has
already technically been done and
confirmed
jamie foxx's electro is going to be in
spider-man 3. so there's definitely a
big possibility that this could be
andrew garfield spider-man since elektra
is already heading to our main universe
but an alternate edition of this theory
slash a part
two garfield gets killed spider-man
actually gets sent to andrew garfield's
amazing spider-man universe
peter is obviously in big trouble more
likely he's clearly going to be wanted
by the law perhaps dr strange sends him
to a different universe to get away for
a little bit
and in this universe peter parker has
just died there is no more spider-man
but
he can train and teach miles morales to
be the next spider-man oh he's the
mentor
that we could see especially because
andrew garfield spider-man isn't exactly
everybody's favorite spider-man they
could choose to kill his spider-man off
however let's remember that miles
morales actually does exist in tom
holland's spider-man
mcu universe in spider-man homecoming
donald glover aka childish gambino
played
miles morales uncle and he mentioned
smiles confirming that he does exist in
the mcu
but that would mean a spider-man in the
main mcu timeline would have to die
i don't know if they'll bring the
prowler in here tom holland's peter
parker has to die
this could be the work of doctor strange
it has been confirmed that doctor
strange is going to take on the role of
peter parker's mentor
in spider-man 3. now obviously peter is
in a lot of trouble in the main mcu
timeline
and perhaps a way to get him out of this
trouble is to fake
his death which is something that has
kind of happened in the comics before
between peter parker and doctor strange
and if you think about it this would be
a pretty good solution to peter parker's
problem if they fake peter parker's
death whether that be by an illusion or
doctor strange pulling his soul out of
his body briefly
to convince people that he's dead nobody
would really be after people these are
some pretty
great theories man seriously since
spider-man's identity has been revealed
to be
peter parker everybody would think
spider-man is dead as well
and now peter parker only has to change
how he looks just a little bit
get a new identity which probably won't
be too large considering he knows nick
fury and he can go about a relatively
normal life continuing to be an
avenger and trying to finish high school
since doctor strange is
involved this could be a way that we go
about seeing spider-man
die but of course there is the
possibility that tobey maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man do end up in the main mcu
timeline and
one of them die now this still does
solve peter parker's problem
if toby or andrew died as spider-man of
course they would unmask him and realize
that hey this
that's not tom holland yeah this other
random guy is clearly
yeah yeah that was the whole thing i was
thinking the whole time it was clearly
off the hook
and technically they could even say that
it is peter parker that is spider-man
just a different peter parker
and then the last and final option is
that this could be a post-credits scene
for spider-man 3. this could be the
setup for miles morales to eventually
come into the marvel cinematic universe
a lot of people are saying that it's
kind of too soon to bring in miles since
him
and tom hall and spider-man are very
similar to each other so perhaps he's
not coming this movie but could be
coming in the future and the very end of
this film
sets it up to where in his universe the
spider-man dies and he
is going to become the new spider-man
now considering the fact that there is a
rumor going around that says
miles morales has actually already been
cast for the spider-man 3 i'd probably
say this is definitely the least likely
well besides tom hall and spider-man
actually dying but it's still
definitely a possibility i can i would
prefer it is most likely to happen
i prefer it as a post credit scene your
own be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest spider-man
news and theories and be sure to let me
know what you think is going to happen
in the comments down below
don't forget to give this video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof but then again if it was an
audition for a post
credit scene i just don't
see them doing that you know like i
don't think they would do like a bit
scene to do that isn't specific to the
movie i feel like for characters like
miles morales especially they
it would be just like a couple of actors
they would be approaching for it
a solid handful where they could have an
extremely
private i don't know i don't know i've
never been able to
access anything that's supposed to be
top secret
in the hollywood world so i don't know
how people are able to grab this stuff
but the
main thing that makes it believable is
the better they've been pulling it off
of the internet
and that's usually a sign that awkwardly
found something that's important
because usually if it's not they either
like yeah whatever just let it be let
them ruminate
well maybe it's just a completely
legitimate scene featuring a featured
extra
yeah and they just don't want that out
there either so if this
is real if this is a real audition that
that was going around
you know like it doesn't specify miles
morales it's saying young
african-american man
i think it's safe to assume that it's
miles morales based off of the amount of
speculation
sony's still involved with the
spider-man movie spider-verse was a big
success miles morales is a lot more
popular in the zeitgeist now more than
ever it would just make sense
that it's miles morelos there aren't
that many other black characters it
could be
yeah especially the one to give like an
important scene because this sounds like
a scene that has
some type of weight or impact and does
seem in tune
with uh the mos morales origin so i'm
cool with it
it does raise the eyebrow of okay if
spider-man is being reported dead you do
take the mask off
yeah you you would see that that's not
tom holland's face and at the end of far
from home
not only does it say that spider-man
killed mysterio but it also shows tom
holland's face everyone would be like
well that's not peter parker
maybe it's from a different spider verse
it could be the one that sony is
developing marvel's leading this one
though right
this is the one that marvel's leading
yeah at least for the production of this
film yeah from what i've been
reading yeah yeah i could see it being
set up for
maybe like i guess the question then
becomes will
miles morales speed that's sony adjacent
to mcu
live action film or will it be miles
morales inside
of the mcu either way it would be cool
to set him up but i do agree with the
point
that you know tom holland's still in
high school he's still a young kid i
mean if we really want to go with the
like the comics you would want to wait a
while obviously for him to be
older be an actual adult peter parker
but then you could kind of play it a
little loose you could have some free
reign here why not get another miles
morales in here let's do this
i thought the idea of him being like a
mentor in an alternate universe where
you know like in andrew garfield peter
parker had died or something was
actually kind of an interesting idea
because they've made so much out of the
mentors for
peter and now having him pass that along
could be
interesting although yeah i do sort of
agree that especially with all the other
stuff we've been talking about for this
movie and how much
of a multiverse they want to take
advantage of i feel like miles morales
is a character that you would want to
give a very big distinct introduction
toward and yeah teasing him at the end
of something
seems like a good idea because yeah
wherever he shows up you're gonna want
him to have his
big moment to you know make a huge
impression in a spider-man movie and so
being just another one of many and also
having to compete with like
returning actors in other contexts and
stuff like that i can see yeah maybe
this
wouldn't be the time to full and
introduce them especially with sony
talking about potentially
because of all these rumors of andrew
garfield and toby maguire not being
verified and now people are saying that
maybe they want to give them their own
movies instead of putting them in this
movie i can see a universe
pretty soon where sony probably just has
a spider verse that kind of overlaps
with the mcu in certain coordinated ways
so maybe they want to do this all at
once but
yeah i don't know this was just more
than anything very interesting and it
got me excited
for the fact that miles morales is
definitely around the bend very soon
oh yeah i think they have um like
undoubtedly they have plans to at least
bring him in at some point
right what i love though about it is if
this is included in here it's like you
want everyone to get proper screen time
and with the amount that they're
including in here where you're like okay
who's gonna be actual characters who's
gonna be
cameos you know like dr strange seems to
be confirmed to be an actual character
in here not just a cameo
whereas electro the way at least the the
news broke
sounded like he's an actual character in
here
not blue but with miles morales i don't
mind like teasing him a little bit and
setting him
up like the mcu is one of the rare
franchises
where i feel like i can be content with
yeah that's just for something to set up
for the future
but what i love about it in terms of
character development for miles morales
and introducing him
is that this is the movie where the
world is hating spider-man right now
the world views him as a murderer yet
miles morales
does not view him that way he thinks
he's still a hero so maybe there was
some encounter
earlier that they had in the movie that
we don't know about where peter parker
saved him or something like that
he still views him as a hero despite the
fact that he's this
wanted fugitive that they're obviously
aiming to gun down or kill
as based off of that news report scene
you know and probably know this could
just be something
written up yeah it's just for the
audition
yeah yeah just just so they can have
something to audition people with but
not
something that's actually a part of the
the script itself
but i love the news that they've been
taking it off the internet that's
usually
yes it's significant in some way shape
or form and the last thing i thought of
and actually you pointed out during the
reaction is i guess i don't want them to
rush it too because i feel like they set
something
pretty nice up with having aaron davis
and the promise of
a potential prowler presence with donald
glover and donald glover is a notable
person i feel like you wouldn't want to
just rush past so i feel like if they
can you know
yeah work a way in to have miles morales
and him kind of return that could also
be cool so i
yeah i don't want them to rush that in
favor of just having a big old
multiverse salad
yeah yeah especially because of
spider-man 3. yeah
yeah yeah exactly reaching this let's
not do this again guys
it's like the garfield didn't even make
it to three let's let's make sure we
stick a spider-man 3
the first time anyone's ever done that
yeah and i think if they do kill the
last thing i'll say is they do kill off
a spider-man
if it's going to be garfield or maguire
i would prefer it to be toby mcguire so
that way he can have some proper
send-off that he didn't that he
he honestly deserved it there's
something about the garfield one where
i'm like
yeah just whatever just drop it
but the mcguire one was such an
important part
of comic book film adaptation history
and it had such an impact that's one
that i feel like people
have wanted it to properly conclude
so maybe do that at the same time though
i if they are
going to kill let's say that is true i
don't think it's going to be andrew
garfield or tommy
i think it's going to be some other
random spiderman yeah peter parker is
going to leave his mcu universe and then
bully mcguire is going to take his place
and live the rest of his days out as a
jazz loving pete
all right guys well cosmic wonder thanks
for putting this video together buddy
always staying up to date on the latest
scoops love you dude subscribe to cause
wonder if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects would
really appreciate if you can hit that
like button as well
catch you guys soon here there's a
mandalorian trailer tonight i'm gonna
wear this shirt all day now